we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about we've
done CrossFit white I surf said cardio
Michigan boot it's your body
I'm Andre and I'm physically mentally
and spiritually cross with Greg Glassman
is the founder of CrossFit we began in
the 1890s opened up his first boxer
Santa Cruz California in 1995 and then
it's just involved worldwide we're
mainly based upon powerlifting and
Olympic lifting movements gymnastic
movements and thirdly - drugs from
English your Olympic lifts being a clean
injure a snatch
we got powerlifting that than this we
have power trains we're putting our body
through unbelievable training in order
to get to an elite level that we're all
trying to strive for that all involves
into a better person in the outside
world so that's why I've chosen cross it
that's why I believe in CrossFit that's
why I believe each and every person on
planet earth should be doing Crossfit
here's the CrossFit three-minute workout
so if you can't get your butt to across
certain box we haven't in home workout
then you could perform in three minutes
so I got Eric you by my side he's gonna
be my wide partner in crime the Burpee
for example first he's gonna be
thrusting his legs back and getting him
to a push-up position he's gonna drop
his chest and hips to the ground and
they're fishing in as quickly as
possible to hop back up they tie his
hands behind his ears
go get as many reps as you can let's go
one thattaboy
two seconds we got thrusters a thruster
is a front squat into a press we're
gonna be using dumbbells to perform this
movement and he's gonna be holding into
what's called a full rack position get
it going come on
good all the way down all the way up
beautiful 13 we got Kenna bus moves I've
ever had formed the kettlebell soon
before I've done something like this
before yeah explain to me what you got
going on here so with the kind of
busting I'm gonna perform at first just
so you can observe kind of like whoa
don't worry
you want to make sure that the cables
out in front and you're almost in a
delicate position when I'm dipping down
I'm actually like a partial squat in my
chest up nice and high and I'm driving
my hips are cheating the cat above you
right above my head getting that full
range of motion
and also have a government of yours
perform the double Monday before sorry
like little drug boats so it's two
revolutions of the rope getting
underneath your feet on one jump slowly
music come on come on come on
and last but not least we got we got
what's called an AB mat signal so within
an atom a sit-up I'm gonna have Eric
sitting on the ground as you can see
there's a bigger hump on the AB mat on
the top lower on the bottom and I want
the bigger hump on his lower back the
idea behind this is to eliminate the hip
flexors that we were getting the entire
abdomen region when we're performing
this he's going to go all the way back
right bottom of his hands touching the
ground going back and - leaning forward
touching your ground in front of his
toes
thank finishing you back off with
burpees once again
once time and that's out right guys you
don't need equipment you can grab any
kind of object at home as long as you're
keeping the intensity up whatever
movement you can even possibly think to
the workouts gonna be great all right so
the workout 30 seconds of burpees
followed by 30 seconds of thrusters then
30 seconds of kettlebell swings 30
seconds of butterfly situps
for 30 seconds of double unders and then
topping it off with burpees once again I
feel sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes